Un arsenal juridique qui soit beaucoup plus fort
pour arriver à faire entendre notre voix.
C'est difficile de retenir une seule avancée
parce que je pense qu'il y a eu beaucoup, beaucoup de choses
qui ont été concrétisées depuis notre arrivée en 2019.
La présence de tous les députés européens
de notre délégation nous permet véritablement
d'avancer dans cet objectif d'une Europe qui soit plus verte,
qui soit plus juste, qui soit plus démocratique, qui s'affirme.
Et ça, c'est un package global.
En fait, ce n'est pas juste un seul texte,
c’est un changement de dogme, un changement de mentalité
et c'est ce qu'on a réussi à construire,
et c'est ce qu'on veut continuer de construire.
Je pense que le Mouvement Démocrate
et les députés européens du Mouvement Démocrate
ont apporté leur singularité dans l'exercice du mandat
parce que ce qui nous caractérise, c'est d'être des Européens.
On a toujours porté les valeurs humanistes,
les valeurs européennes.
Ce qui nous renforce, c'est notre présence aussi sur le territoire.
C'est ce lien permanent entre nos territoires, nos terroirs,
le niveau national, le niveau européen.
C'est vraiment une singularité
très forte du Mouvement Démocrate
et du Parti démocrate européen.
Le mandat de député européen ?
Il a renforcé mes convictions européennes.
Parce qu'effectivement j'étais,
de par mes engagements associatifs,
de par mon engagement politique,
convaincue que l'Union Européenne est le bon échelon
pour répondre à certains enjeux.
Le choc du COVID, la réponse qu'on a apportée en européen,
le soutien à l'Ukraine qu'on peut fournir
à l’heure actuelle en européen,
démontrent à quel point l'Union Européenne est une nécessité.
Merci l'Europe de nous protéger,
de protéger nos entreprises, nos emplois, nos agriculteurs,
nos savoir-faire, nos territoires.